[Laughter]
my life my life my life my life
in the sunshine
[Laughter]
wagon you soppy buggers yo people
um i started sitting like this the last
couple episodes
it's kind of like feminine but it's like
i don't know it's just comfortable
because i was gonna say
it looks good it is comfortable you feel
like
you feel like small spoon in it yeah
yeah yeah i love being a small spoon
spoon is hot too mmm small spoon no guy
can say with his chest that he doesn't
like me in a small spoon
the first time i experienced small spoon
i was like i never want this to go back
um
small spoon when the goal is small as
well oh
her little hand just covered you here i
don't know why it just feels amazing i
don't care i
arch my back as well when i'm in there
and a cold night on a winter's night
fam and she she gets on my back is
arched
the cold winter's night oh that's
hilarious
ah bro when it's cold like now i wanna
snuggle no oh
bro bro i know the pain and i know the
feeling
been there i want to snuggle i don't
want to be in bed alone i want a snug
snug
i want to be in bed alone bro you know
you get into a cold bed
and you're like nah my bed's freezing
all the time it drives me insane
i don't know what's wrong with it oh my
god yeah my worst fear is getting
getting back into a corbett i'm not i'm
not a fan um
but anyway we're here guys welcome guys
um welcome
newer dish um as usual
it is uh february
yeah so get your flipping
uh video submissions in if you're on the
patreon
get yourself video valentine's
submissions in 60 second clip run it
through to us
and we'll get it on the show hopefully
if it's a juicy juice
um yeah so send us in your worst
valentine's
experience and obviously hop on the
patreon for the bonus episodes the juicy
content
uncensored unapologetic fandom only if
you're not part of the fandom then you
don't belong here
gang obviously it's cheaper it's a part
of the problem it's literally cheaper
than chips
fam it's cheap parliament chips it's not
cheaper chips it's cheaper than chips
10p
a day they're running tempe i'll lose
more than 10p a day
rags i'll just lose it right i'll throw
it rags just give it to us
um tempe a day run me my p um and then
obviously
the valentine's merch is out and about
so
live jump on that that ends end of feb
so um yeah man enjoy that
i never got anything else to plug um my
only fan starts
tomorrow so for that bonus bulge
follow the link in the description to my
only fans mine started yesterday because
i'm poor so
bro yeah we
that picture i sent in the group chat
the other day yes for the 15k
yes oh i would do it
we already established we'd all do it i
will arch my back and spread my legs for
15k a month 50.
there's a lot i can't get my words out
there's not much that i wouldn't do for
15k a month
it's basically what i'm trying to say
there's um so
i hate plugging other pods all the time
but you know i love watching the fire on
the kid
of course one of their producers is
called cat
okay she um ages ago ages ago i'm
talking about a year or two ago
they made a joke about she she's
this was before only found was like a
big thing for like regular people to
just do
they made a joke that she should um sell
pictures of her feet
okay and then apparently from then she
just constantly got messages from
guys offering to buy pictures of her
feet oh really she just never did it
and recently she jumped to noni fans
okay and it's just feet stuff
okay she's making k's off the bat oh my
off the bat oh my
so yeah because obviously you can't i
might be wrong but obviously you can't
see how many subscribers someone has on
any fans i think maybe you can i don't
know well i haven't i've only clicked on
like i only know like the home page
okay i've only clicked on like the home
page and then it says but
it shows the post kind of like patreon
it shows the post obviously blurred out
yeah yeah of course yeah but then it
will say how many likes are on there
okay and you show you you can see
obviously what their minimum charge is
yeah i see the tears basically you can
see the two just like patreon you can
see the tears
you see how many likes it's got so you
kind of know around about how many
people are subscribed to that
and you're like she's making a healthy
chunk of change you know you already
know she's making she's making at least
this much funny enough i saw her on
twitter because i'm an
avid twitter i'm an avid tweeter rather
or retweeter
if i should say that um someone's um
some important only on only found
someone
on twitter that they made a hundred bags
this year from only five or in the last
12 months
so 100 bags is 100 000 or pounds
whatever you want to call it 100 bags
this year
in the last 12 months the last 12 months
ah
from only family from only fantastic 100
000 pounds
or dollars whichever one it was i was
having this conversation with jay the
other day
um on call of duty we're getting into
good conversations on call of duty
i've heard is actually we get into good
deconvos
yeah yeah warzone yeah if any of you
guys jump on warzone yeah let me know
what your loadout is
let me know where the good spots in the
dance car um i'm on i'm on warzone every
night
[Laughter]
um but anyway yeah we're talking about
only fans and it's like
i think it's a really cool thing as a
means to an
end okay but just for how
motivation works and like uh drive works
as a person it kind of like
don't you think it's like a weird like
it's a weird cheat code that everyone's
just like
so what do i do now i'm making more
money than i can
dream about fathom yeah and it's like
i'm only gonna make it for the next few
years
yeah maybe not even next year yeah
like i would just assume that people are
just like
using it as a way because they need
money for this yeah
like i want to start this or i want to
do this or i want to take a year off
work and i want to do this
or i just need to get out of debt and
stuff like that's why i'm doing it like
i would always imagine that but
obviously that's not the case yeah
people just want to make p
quick of course and it is the fastest
way to make people understand
yeah if you take it seriously and you've
already got a big following yeah and you
jump on
bang you've made p from the jump
and it's but yeah but then like i would
always be concerned that like
my followers are just gonna get bored
tomorrow why
because there's everyone they've got to
choose from they've got so many people
to choose from
okay fair enough and obviously like it's
a monthly monthly thing yeah
so like what more can i bring to the
table do you know what once i've sat
on a few dildos like what else can i do
for you you as a man or you're talking
about like women
women in general or if it was me as a
man whatever okay okay
um whatever they needed me to do yeah
yeah yeah but
yeah like at what point i would be
always thinking like what's going to
convince this person to sign on for a
year
true and after that year what's going to
make him do the second year
yeah it's i guess it's more of the
in my assumption anyway it's more of the
interaction more of the engagement the
same way
on our podcast on our instagram for
example the more we interact the more we
do like would you rather
the more we post the more we do this the
more we do that people are always going
to comment and people are always going
to
um be interactive with us um even though
our content is different every single
week i just feel like
once you start something once you're a
fan of someone or something you're just
always going to be there
even if you're paying like the three
pound a month yeah like
our patreon for example you're paying
three pound a month regardless of
whether you watch everything or
regardless of whether
um we post daily or we post weekly place
monthly on it people are just still
gonna pay for it and people are still as
long as they they
they ride with us then i don't feel like
people care that nes
necessarily that much but obviously it's
a different sensation when it with only
five only fans yeah it's definitely
different
it's more it's more one-on-one etc so
that's if you actually speak to the
person that's going to say well it's all
one-on-one until you've got flipping 10
000
subscribers you know what i mean like
yeah yeah then what are you doing bro i
mean then i'm assuming
it's literally their only job because
you've got 10 000 subscribers and you
want to be a one-on-one person actually
talk to everyone that talks to you then
you can't do anything else true they're
not doing that fam
okay you don't know a lot i know they're
not i know for a fact that they're not
you don't know you don't know you don't
know that's probably how they get busy
or stay busy rather and get the pee
that's how they get sucked in oh brav
that's
i would do it but it's just damn i would
actually do all defense
i mean i'm definitely just gonna be gay
guys i know that's i was thinking
i'm not thinking about doing early fans
but i was thinking about that concept of
men doing only fans i've got no stigma
against early fans period so whether
you're male or female i don't really
care if you do it get your back whatever
but i just don't i can't really
comprehend like
obviously the target market for men's
only fans i'm assuming
is necessarily for just gay guys of
course or like the vast majority for gay
guys like
i don't see the thrill of women looking
at a guy
doing stuff unless my obviously my other
assumption is
for guys or any fans that they always
have to partner with someone like they
always get chicks involved
oh right yeah yeah that's my other
assumption but if you're doing a solo
tip
what's sexy about him in my opinion i
don't know so like i said it's only
going to be
um the gay audience you're you're trying
to target and
it's also a bit i don't know
i just don't understand not necessarily
understand i just can't
put myself in a in an environment where
or mentally put myself in an environment
where i know my target audience is
um for the gay community so i have to
actually look like i'm enjoying what i'm
doing
while i'm doing the solo team and this
game man i'm just going to let you
let you just post a news yeah yeah you
better get in our stuff they want stuff
they want they want the filth exactly
because i feel i'm assuming it's
um easier or a lot less there's a lot
less you have to think about if you're a
woman
doing solo stuff trying to post for men
all posts for women
because it's sex in my opinion because
i'm a male i'm assuming so i'm a biased
it's sexier to look at female solo stuff
than it is male solo stuff
i would say so so i don't know who
actually does know like the
the if men that do only funds are
plugging for the gay community they
could be making racks on racks
they are making wrecks you know so i've
heard some some stories
i don't know gee but i'm not doing that
for
for man i mean well i would for the for
those
if if it was a 30 10 bags a month that's
what i'm saying for the p like
certified 10 bags a month i would do it
for a few months
yeah and then if it was certified 20
bags i'm doing it
until the world until
until i physically can't do it anymore
it's um
it's weird but i like i said i have no
issue against it i feel like
a lot there's a huge stigma about it
especially for women obviously yeah yeah
um in the sense that women people feel
like
the women that do do only fans are just
like hoes or [ __ ] and blah blah and
that's
that that's all they like and that's all
they um that's part of the appeal of it
though as well
of course you imagine that they are it
doesn't matter if they are or not
you just imagine that they are and
that's the appeal the appeal is what
it's there for and
um any news any news any feedback is
good for you that kind of thing so if
people are talking about whether they're
shaming you or cussing your problem it's
getting your name out there and
obviously
it comes with a territory if you know
you're going to do early fans and um you
know you're going to reach certain
target markets and everything you just
have to be prepared for the backlash
the same way we have to be prepared for
backlash on our podcast
it just kind of is what it is you know
being prepared well comment section was
blowing up today
comments is it in my car
they sent feed for no reason oh god like
why did you send for us guys like we're
just here for
yeah you have a bit of fun in here
literally here for shits and kids to
make you happy man um
but anyway um fun fact uh yes a quick
one um
do you know that there's uh obviously
because of the situation we're in now um
the pandemic
depending on where you are in the world
obviously um but in the uk currently you
still can't
um go to um like clothes stores and well
clothes um
clothes stores are closed at the moment
but when they were open at a time you
couldn't try stuff on
due to obviously like yay contamination
whatever
so apparently i saw on tick tock that as
a way you can test
whether jeans or trousers fit you
without putting them on and
it's the length the length of your elbow
to your your forearm on your wrist
rather if it fits in the hole perfectly
it will fit your waist and if you wrap
the jeans around your neck and it
both of the ends touch it will fit you
as well
because you know the um you know that
human proportion thing that stands like
this
yeah so yeah that the width of your the
width of your forearm is the same size
as your waist or similar sides of yours
and if you kind of
if you slit your neck and open it up the
circumference of that is the size of
your waist as well
so those are two ways to try on try on
jeans or trousers without actually
trying them on to know if they fit
ah okay i guess there's like a
gray error because i'm assuming like for
women for example if you've got like
massive hips
what i was going to say as well like
what if i'm fat that's what i was going
to say
like well my forum ain't doing nothing
because
maybe it's for like proportionate people
maybe but maybe maybe not fat people
maybe i don't know but
this is why i've been told anyway so
i've tried it on because as soon as i
as soon as i saw it i tried it i put my
forearm in and it fit and i've wrapped
around my neck it wraps around so i was
thinking oh
wrap what are engineering so obviously
you grab the two ends of the jeans or
whatever and you wrap
you get one tip again the other tip and
then wrap it around your neck like here
oh
two tips touch like comfortably not like
tight then it will comfortably fit
around your waist
supposedly supposedly yeah so try out if
you guys let me know if it's fact or cat
fair play fact or cap
there's a new little one i like that um
right let's have a look-see
um i have a fan request
hit me up gg what uh
damn phenol ether i represented a word
but speaking of music why are you
looking for a fan because do you not
feel like we've let some musicians get
away with murder when it comes to the
lyrics like
um sure is it sean paul there's a camera
what song it is where he says
5 million and 40 naughty shorties five
million i'm farting
what is that bro what is that bro what
is that
bro have we let him just get away with
such we've been saying it for years
what song is it does it get busy i can't
remember 5 million and forty ninety
sharties
baby girl shanna policy oh man the way
the time yeah man i can't remember what
song is
where is it are you trying to find a
fanny
no uh yeah
okay cool this is probably in your pile
because you replied all right say let's
hit me
but it's sweet i mean when i saw it and
i was like oh yeah yeah yeah
right so this thought yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
16 from oz yeah australia
australia hopped on the uh podcast a few
months ago and [ __ ] with a heavy thank
you sir
anyway so don't usually yeah yeah right
cool
anyway so don't usually uh you i say
brown cow how now brown cow anyway how
now brown cow is that does that like
just like to articulate your [ __ ] is it
how now brown cow
and what is it um i don't know they do
one with elves i can't remember
like three little lemons licking lips
like that
tip um no is it the tip of the tongue
um tip of the tongue teeth and the lips
that's what it is it sounds like
something stewie griffin would say oh
yeah he probably has it
the tip of the tongue teeth and the lips
that's asmr [ __ ]
like you know right let me revert let's
go again
16. from oz hopped on the pod
a few months ago [ __ ] with it heavy
anyway so usually don't cuff [ __ ]
but there is one bad bad shorty i've
been chatting
but she playing hard to get i remember
readers
when i read this she was uh she's always
sending me videos and replying to my
snaps consistently yeah yeah and we chat
sometimes but whenever i tell her to
come out and see me
she sends a photo of her smiling what
the actual [ __ ] does that mean
[Laughter]
what the actual [ __ ] does that mean uh
i've got multiple [ __ ] in my snap
trying to [ __ ]
but for some reason i keep chasing this
painting
should i keep trying to pursue her
because if i do
eventually get to see um wait he put a
full stop
for no reason pursue her because if i do
eventually get
to see get her to see me it's a done
deal
okay confident i know how to deal with a
[ __ ] face to face oh my
oh my or should i just leave it and
spend less time and energy
on shorties um who are already trying to
[ __ ]
but aren't as buff or should i juggle
all these [ __ ]
somehow much love so funny right
before we get into it yeah yeah do you
know why for starters
this made me laugh so much the first
time i read it why
because obviously my man's from
australia yeah but he's dropping the
most
detroit slang and i remember thinking
when i'm reading it i'm thinking
yo what does my man sound like when he
says that
mind i don't really cuff [ __ ] i don't
really cuff butchers but this is bad bad
shorty
a proper sheila a right ripper
there's a right ripper she's always in
me [ __ ] private snaps
but every time i turn to come see me
she sends a picture of me smiling what
the [ __ ] even is that
i lost it there that's hilarious i said
i know how to deal with a [ __ ] face to
face
that's aggressive you're
16 bro i know how to deal with a [ __ ]
face-to-face
16 man that's aggressive
sometimes it baffles me i don't think
wait give me the summary before i even
get into right get into editing sorry
so he's 16 yeah he's chatting to a ting
yeah who he thinks is buff yeah they
have a little chit chat here and there
but every time it gets to the point
where he's like yo come see
your boy she just sends a picture of him
her smiling
and he's like cool what even is that
um and then
nothing ever happens he keeps chasing it
chasing it and he's thinking
big man if i can just get her to link me
yeah
it's a wrap yeah but these times
while i'm trying to get her to lick me
and she's just playing hard to get
i've got bear things
just chilling in my phone okay
and i'm thinking do i keep pursuing this
one thing
or do i cut her off and just cut my
losses and move on to the things that
are less buff but i know they're trying
to smash
or do i try and juggle everyone
[Laughter]
at 16 i feel like
that you're you man are living in
different worlds yeah they're different
they weren't they're not thinking about
things that i was thinking about
because the last few either fan requests
or am i the art stores we've been
reading out or
seeing like 15 years ago this was 15 16
14 years ago this wasn't happening to us
like what um when i was 16 do you think
i have the confidence to tell someone i
know how to deal with a [ __ ] face to
face
i didn't have to do a knight in cuz i
didn't have to run a bath i didn't have
to deal with puberty
let alone a [ __ ] face to face oh never
i definitely didn't know how to handle a
[ __ ] face to face
i would tremor face to face
it always brings me back to the story
when you said um the thing you fancy
dragged when you went back to the yard
to get money for a trim or something she
came into the island and stared at you
face
and you ran up i ran upstairs you
running upstairs with a bone i found
runners
with a bone and screamed into my pillow
what's wrong with you
james bro i was so angry at myself i'm
such a [ __ ]
but um well considering you said that
um she's playing hard to get then i
don't feel like
i don't feel like necessarily you need
to you need to force yourself into
getting getting that one or getting hurt
because she's clearly playing hard to
get for a reason maybe she is feeding
maybe she's not maybe she's just
having fun bro a lot of girls not
necessarily a lot of girls people
tend to or girls tend to flirt with
people when they're bored
fam i was going to say the exact
sentence you just said girls flirt with
guys when the girls flirt because
they're bored especially during pandemic
or lockdown
when they've got nothing else to do they
will flirt with you literally
disgusting behavior it is disgusting
behavior i've i've been a victim
i've been a victim we all have we all
have and it's um
it's not necessarily a hard pill to
swallow because it is what it is and is
they don't owe you a thing there's no
sense of entitlement in that aspect
but because of the fact that she's not
your only option i don't think you
should really sweat on it and
you don't doesn't sound like you are
sweating on it but it's also
i feel like you're you're also i feel
like you're a bit way too big for your
boots like
you're 16 years old you're talking about
you having um [ __ ] all
up in your snapchat that you can [ __ ]
out a drop of a hat you can handle a
[ __ ] face to face blah blah blah she's
sending you thumbs up or whatever smiley
face
when you're trying to link just chill
she's she's clearly not as down as you
think and she's just making you run
around she's making run hoops she's
making more hoops
it's a bit that's a bit long she knows
what she's doing
um but here's the play if you want some
real advice this is what you need to do
right go for it
right so in these situations
you just need to turn to the godfather
himself
mr bruno mars okay and you're like bae
listen to me
you're sending me all these pictures i'm
telling you to run through i'm shouting
you
and you're not having it babes i've got
alicia waiting
i've got aisha waiting big man i got all
the issues waiting on me
[Laughter]
and while you're over there
contemplating play hayden
if this is what it's going to be big man
i'm calling on my lovelies i'm calling
all my lovelies because i can't get hold
of
you
what a rhythm calling all my lovely
recite the lyrics to calling all my
lovers to her
and she'll she'll come to her senses
real quick or probably just
error that's i feel like that's the next
best thing if that doesn't work just
error bro because
women want guys that don't want them and
because of the fact that you guys have
been going back and forth back and forth
on snap if one day you just stop
or for a couple of two days or a period
of time you just stop she's going to be
like oh where's he going canada yeah
because she's her entertainment value is
keeping you entertained oh
so she loves the fact that you want her
back exactly and every time she gets you
to the point where you're like yo come
like me come make me come look at me
you're thinking in your head if i can
just get this [ __ ] to link me
she doesn't know what she's in for she's
she's not stupid because
she's never gonna ever gonna link you
because the game is the game ends there
for her she's
playing chess you're playing checkers on
boy i'm sorry
there is you're stuck playing checkers
she's playing queen's gambit she's been
playing queen's gambit boy
she's never gonna leave her yard cuz
it's not a case of you
being able to get her out and once you
get her there is there well she's six
steps
she's never gonna leave she's never
gonna leave you she's doing this
this same picture that she says to you
smiling she's sent to seven other
brothers
guys and she's got a mane that she's
sucking off now in a row yeah so
she's just bored because but yeah
literally once you're in that routine
with her of like flirt flirt flirt
come lick me ed flirt flirt come link me
ed yeah flat flirt trust me bruv stop
asking to link her
stop replying take a day or two to reply
yeah
she'll clock that you're losing interest
and one shall ever
truly show her colors and be like i
definitely didn't give a [ __ ] about this
guy anyway and then
you'll never hear from her again which
is probably for the best yeah or two
should i i don't like it when he hears
me she might double down yeah he might
double down and then she'll say
something along the lines of so when are
we going to meet then what are you
forgotten about hey big head
it's one of them ones but you gotta play
the game man the game will always be the
game for a soon
you're clearly in the game she's clearly
been in the game longer than you
even though you say you've got [ __ ]
here they're and everywhere they're
clearly not doing it for you you clearly
like the chase and she clearly likes
beating chase
yeah g she's you have to play smart you
have to play hard man yeah play smart
10 steps ahead i know you think you're
you're crushing the game right now but
she's duped you and you didn't even know
i didn't know you're elementary right
now she's in secondary school
she's been about the game bro i feel
like that's that's the best way because
it's all i feel like it's gonna happen
throughout your teens and like probably
20s as well because you're 16 and this
is
this is a problem for you so you just
have to you just have to take this l
per se and just keep moving man because
like you said it's not like you're in a
drought if you're in a drought we can
understand
you've clearly like you said got things
on your line so you can
you can still have the fun you want
regardless of whether you said um
they're not as fine as this chick
but boy you're not getting anywhere with
her right now
not going anywhere with me sometimes you
need to just take a step back and
look at your life exactly you know what
i mean she realized like rah like i'm
actually not achieving
anything what you need to do if you've
saved the chat on snapchat you said
smoke you speak on
snapchat scroll through the messages and
see the progress you've actually made
do you know what i mean because you only
ever think about the here and now in the
comments yeah yeah yeah
if you scroll through it's about three
four days ago five days ago last week
two months ago
and you see it's the same routine the
same cycle you will see she's taking you
for a mug big man when i was in flipping
that reminds me of van storchels
vancouver used to do that to me all the
time when i was what 19
yeah van storchels had me running ragged
and i thought i was making progress
she was 17 steps ahead for him every
time good book like did i do
the flip flop flip flip flirt oh let's
do a thing let's go out on a date let's
go cinema should be like yeah yeah yeah
cinema tomorrow et cetera et cetera
tomorrow never come i would never hear
from her fam
i'll never hear from her there's me like
babies we're still going come on
you must be you must be sleeping i'll
check in there's a and then i'll check
in again i must be sleeping
you check it again like um what was it
what was it you're taking again like oh
um
yeah yeah yeah um i was just taking a
break from
revising and i saw that avengers is on
there six of uh
uh if you're interested these times you
look back and it's just my message my
message my message my missus my message
and you're like oh and then she'll
message you two days later like oh sorry
about the other day i fell asleep
or something like that it's um it's hard
to find it's a hard pill to swallow and
you don't only realize it
until you're out of this situation yeah
yeah yeah situation or
yeah like i said try and look at it from
a third perspective if you scroll
through your chats you're gonna
understand like boy she's not actually
feeling she's here to like
make you run circles around her you have
you have things ready waiting for you so
just forget about her man yeah do your
time
that's just the honest truth yeah man
put your money where your mouth is
that's what i'm saying put your
you can deal with a [ __ ] face to face
prove it prove it [ __ ] prove it
big boy goodnight mike
good eye mate i've got a real rib
the ah that he's australian and you said
that he's speaking with this kind of
yeah i've got a real shorty
american accent oh i got a filthy little
shorty
i'm really trying to cuff him um
hopefully that
solves your issue but it's a tough pill
to swallow and you're just going to have
to swallow it might you
oh for real for real game game gang g
um all right so
[Music]
i wanted to talk to you about something
hit me up broski
oh that was what it was trash news
that's what it was
in a while yeah we already spoke about
this one already but we didn't flesh it
out because it was just on message
okay okay this one f thing
one f
how scary is that oh my god give them
context
now so there was a story that i
saw the other day so basically there's
this woman who lives alone
and she went out uh it's snowing um and
she
she went outside as she was i don't know
what she's doing leaving for work she
was just
going outside the house and she looked
on her dustbin
and there was the number one with an f
next to it
so my girl took to tick-tock she
recorded it put it on tik-tok and asked
tick-tock
what is this what does this mean fam the
comments blew
up they said big man one f somebody's
did you read any of the comments no i it
wasn't did you send it to me on tick
tock you sent us
i think no i said yeah i said the
instagram but these there's screenshots
of
on the instagram if you scroll across
the screen these men were saying it like
it's largely dark
it's casual oh yeah it means one female
one female you know one female means the
man that are about to rob you
know that you live alone know that you
live alone and then letting the the
homies know that is a female living by
itself
wow i don't know how scared i would be
in that situation that is
i because i've never actually seen that
live so seeing that
because i didn't know what it was until
you showed up no i'm thinking
what kind of world is this that is the
scariest thing
one f you know i'll be petrified she
lives alone how long have you been
stalking my house
clearly you've been doing recon fam
you've been doing recon and some of the
comments were
saying i'm suggesting that oh change it
to three
m or something like that or get yourself
a gun or do this something
or move but the way they were saying it
the way they were planning was so casual
not not called the police
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this one has to
change it to three f how do you even
know what the one f means but yeah i'm
changing it to four immediately i change
the four m
i'm scrubbing the whole bin i'll scrub
the whole thing fam
and i'll scream in the street someone's
watching me what's the one and i'll say
please don't
ah this is scary don't rob me it's the
scariest thing
oh it was in america is it i don't know
where it was g
but um yeah if you ever see one f on
your bin
in the snow or just use something or
whatever just know that they're about
yeah if there's a number and a letter
just on your bin for no reason
you're next
just know you're next i'll panic if i
saw that
thing is even if obviously it's scary as
it is
that it's a one like one female thing
that they know that you're by yourself
yeah i'd still be scared if there was me
and all the older all the fellas living
in the house together
and i came outside and it said 6m fam it
means they're ready to come strapped
they don't care
they don't care imagine though imagine
you walk out you see 6m
i'm like i'll run back in every man wake
up
every man wake up we're next
we're next now with our unbolt in the
window is everything
i will i would tell them to come i'm
ready
to bench would i'd write underneath
that's wish you would
oh my god that's scary scary that is
that is one of the scariest things
you've ever like sent in the group chat
i couldn't believe it bro
i actually couldn't believe it it's too
scary and speaking of actually
another one that i had to trash news
ages ago this is actually a while ago
but this one was the scariest thing did
you see again on tick tock
the lady that was trying to do a video
and donnie broke into her house
it was a couple months ago now
i want to say yes but give me context
let me set up for this one this one was
scary
okay so there was a a lady in her
apartment
first floor apartment by the way or
first or second floor
she's doing tick-tock dances and [ __ ]
and while she's recording obviously the
phone's on the floor
um up against the wall she's like
dancing in the living room
fam she's got like a balcony door
here so she's dancing over here there's
a balcony door
fam you can see in the camera the door
just opens
and then your man's face just pops
through and he says nothing
it pops through like that and he's just
staring at her and she's and she's
dancing back and then she clocks like in
the corner of my eyes she stumbles
and she's like who are you who are you
from she's panicked like who are you
who are you who are you a man said
mexican don i said in this it sounds
like like this
i'm your friend yes she's like no
please get out and she's starting to cry
please get out please get out i'm your
friend
yes fam
she panicked she screamed please get out
please get out please big man please
leave please and you just stare down
hang on a thing
didn't say anything just stared at her i
couldn't see that and she sprinted out
and then you can just see him like close
the door slowly and she's banging on the
next door neighbor like let me let me
let me in
and the next one neighbor lets her in
and then the video cuts but
then it comes out he got arrested turns
out he was just like a guy that lives in
the neighborhood that's been stalking
her
and he climbed up the fire escape to get
into a balcony door
the man just peeked that that alone is
the scariest thing i can never see that
fam i could never see that just
nonchalant all my manhood would bleed
away in that one moment or without a
shadow of that i would be he fears
nothing yeah
oh [ __ ] i'll be the best this is nothing
[ __ ] in that moment i would scream
i was screaming scurry you know that
once when you trip when you're like
and you find the wall and your hands are
just up on the wall you'll be that [ __ ]
in the movie that falls over
no no no no no no
you must be fam you're my friend
i wouldn't if i'm your friend yes
fam no get the [ __ ] out she's brave to
even be like please leave please leave i
would have been discriminated
i would love to imagine that i would be
screaming and stuff like trying to
protect myself or whatever but i've
because i've never been frightened to a
point where
i'm like shell-shocked i i believe i
might
freeze yeah do you know what i mean i
know exactly what your blood runs
[ __ ] ice cold and you're stuck there
and you're just staring at each other i
actually think i might freeze because
that's something you just
the nonchalantness of him just doing
that i'm not doing anything but saying
i'm your friend yes
he's not like he can't run over to her
like give me yeah yeah because that you
can fight back yeah yeah
but i think for me the way i know how my
body works
you know when a cat is scared yes and it
darts
like the strength it exhibits is not
it's not normal because
it says yeah
that would be me after i freeze so if he
comes
through and i'll i'll just be just
tick-tock dancing
yeah and then all i see is this
are you still from my breath would stop
yeah and my blood would
run ice cold and he's like i am your
friend yes
i won't be able to speak and as soon as
he takes one step forward that's
it that's it my body would explode
i'll be leaving off the walls cause the
ones i'll be throwing a million things
in him at once
questions everything everything anything
i could grab get the [ __ ]
out one step further takes one step
forward i'm losing it i'll be like
my larynx would rip
my larynx would actually rip oh
oh i didn't think about the one step
further
a picture in it bro my muscles will
explode with how much adrenaline is
running through me boy
i will run through a wall there's no way
no no way no way i'm not going out like
that no way
i'm not going out when i think about
that i feel you're like it sounds stupid
but like in a really
really weird way i feel like i don't
think i could be killed unless he has a
gun in that moment
yeah as soon as it takes a step forward
but i i'm not human anymore because
i'm doing whatever anything i'm doing i
genuinely feel like i could
beat usain bolt in a run after that
because i will
ah adrenaline is a different thing
adrenaline is a different thing i i
couldn't go out like that
bro that one step forward you know
did he taste did he dart after anything
no he just stayed there
the whole thing after he said your
friend yes and then as soon as she said
please get out peace out she dipped
as she's dipping you see him like close
the door slowly as well
guys the thing's scary have you seen
those one i don't know if i sent it to
you actually
on tick tock as well um there was three
guys in our yard i think
they were like fixing up a yard or
something and
there was a guy looking out he was
fixing something i think on the ground
but up in front of him was a window so
you could see outside
but he realized that something was
looking back at him but it was a mask it
wasn't a face it was a mask
it was one of those i wouldn't say it
was like a halloween mask it was more
like a
it was like a scary clownish kind of
mask it was just staring back at him but
because i say there was two other guys
in the yard
he thought it was one of these boys
playing a prank on him it was like let's
say for example he's like jack is that
you jack is that you
just straight face staring at him like
[Laughter]
this
because you can't see facial expressions
he's wearing a [ __ ] mask he's like
jack is that you jack is that you
and then obviously jack jack's in the
next door jack's in the next room so he
comes in with another guy
saying what's going on what's going on
he's like can you see this
and he's like huh what's this what's the
and the guy is he's not moving
listen to me for that i will kill him or
i'll kill myself in that moment
he's not moving all that's between them
is this glass
that's the scariest thing you've ever
told me this is on tick tock this is on
tick tock the only thing in between them
two is a glass window and then they're
like that's a person
that's a [ __ ] person and as they as
they walk out to try and see he's still
there staring watching them nah
i thought i sent it to you no you
definitely didn't i would have loved my
phone
you definitely i wouldn't have a phone
anymore if you said that to me fam
that's scary
it's one of the scariest things i don't
understand what's happening in this
world
people have got time and they've got
energy for that don't scare me like that
fun
it's not working yeah it's not worth it
because i'm not i'm not responsible for
my actions especially if it's a prank
you're not because you know what it
reminds me of i've said to you a million
times
to this day yeah one of the funniest
things i've ever seen you do look i
don't know
this is your immediate body reflex to
fear
okay it's a jumping fear i think i know
what you're going to say but go for it
so
he already knows but i'll tell the guys
there was a time when we used to live
together
and our housemate aaron was just out
here jumping out on people
and you're gonna say this so what he
would do we had a downstairs bathroom
and if you he would hide in the bathroom
and wait until someone
goes to open the door and he would jump
out at you so i was in the kitchen
and the bathroom's on my right and i'm
just cooking food walks past to go to
the toilet
everyone's hiding in there food opens
the door
aaron jumps out i think that's immediate
reaction
mr probably
it's immediate reaction he
jumped and he squeezed his throat like
that i squeezed his throat
that you that's that's your muscles
moving by themselves
to grab this it wasn't me it was i
wasn't myself funniest thing
i've ever seen who does that who
does that ah i'm not responsible for
reaction i've never laughed so hard
i've never laughed so hard my chest was
it's uh and aaron's face was just fear
fear is shocked she was shell-shocked
getting choked out
oh that's so funny oh my days
oh and that reminds me of like
it's annoying because i wish i was that
guy do you remember there was that video
years ago
of the um the halloween prank where
someone would jump out of the bin
yes and there's a guy that just rocks
him and knocks him back in the beer
yeah yeah i know that's not my reaction
okay my fear like it's not my fault like
my brain is not involved
my immediate reaction is i dip i did
i scream and i dip i'm not ready for i'm
not on it
whatever you're bringing to me i'm not
on it and it annoys me because i'm like
oh i'm not a man you know what i mean
i'm not a man i want to be the guy that
rocks you and there's a heart and then
scared after you yeah yeah yeah
you know you actually used to rock him
and then you're like oh [ __ ] what was
that where's to me
i will scream i'll slip and i would just
get away
the slip will sweep me if i knew it was
a prank and i was involved in a prank
and someone scared you and you try and
die and you slip
oh oh that's going to world style
laughter
my eyes fall out i'm getting hot
oh that was too funny and for those
wondering why the [ __ ] is your bathroom
in the kitchen next to the kitchen oh it
was
it was the weirdest she told her she
told her house in coventry it was a
weird olden time oh
that didn't pass any inspections yeah
didn't pass any of the inspections
it was such a weird house such a weird
house but anyway we moved yeah
oh my gosh humble beginnings what the
time i forgot what the time dude that
was so
funny i forgot about i can never forget
about it
because i've never been so surprised in
my life
it took the breath out of me and the
combination of seeing you do that and
aaron's face
so funny but you obviously knew rem was
there he knew he was waiting for i knew
he was waiting for you
but [ __ ] hell bro i was just in my
towel my wash bag ready to go shower
he's annoying he used to do that all the
time but he used to do it by peeking
behind something so you'll just be
walking or i'll be in my room there's a
lot of times i'll be playing xbox in my
room or something yeah
and then he used to do this as well
so he'd put you know when like um you
put your
eyes around just your eyes around the
door frame but you go like halfway down
the door frame
yeah your proper bed like that yeah and
he's open his eyes wide
so i'll just be playing and he'd go like
this he'll be there
i can't see him yeah and he goes
i remember all the time i don't like
the [ __ ] is that and then you go and you
look and you just stand up
eyes beaming scary as [ __ ]
scariest [ __ ] such a pretty you're such
a freak
bro it's so funny oh my days
oh my days he does that he's so funny
that [ __ ] time when he's satisfied and
you know what
happened the one time
[Laughter]
he taught me he died
i can't breathe hang on for [ __ ] sake
be professional james come on
right he done it one time yeah when i
was lips in a ting
no he done it one time
he done it one time when
so do you remember we went i'm not gonna
out names or anything like that but we
went to a house party
is this in uni i'm assuming yeah well we
all lived together but no it wasn't at
uni
it was in the summer time but it was uni
times okay okay okay but we'd all gone
home for summer okay
we'd driven up north okay not manchester
but the other one yes of course
to go to a house party yes um in the
summertime yes
and then we met a couple yes ladies yeah
one thing led to another so eddie
actually too far
nothing that led to nothing at this
point i met some lovely ladies there
um about seven of us had to sleep in
this one bedroom
like some of us on the bed some of us on
the floor yeah yeah so the way it was
patterned
is there was a girl here there was aaron
there was me on the floor he's all on
the floor lined up and there was another
go here
so me and this other girl were talking
talking talking i remember now
and um the late it's getting late it
must be like 5 a.m at this point
talking talking talking talking turns to
lipson lipson turns to grips in
so i'm saying yeah i hear what you're
saying i'm following you i'm with you
rubs just rubs i'm with you anyway
so we're doing all that mess it's late
everyone's asleep
everyone's asleep apart from aaron
who i thought was asleep because i
looked at him before any of it started
and he was asleep and then
he turned around he had one eye closed
[Laughter]
any other one
i would have screamed i would have woken
everyone it was the funniest
thing of all time out of working little
peeping tom
ah so funny oh my god you went so rem
was saying you were here
so yeah he was here and i was here so we
would be back to as i'm talking to this
girl
he'd be at my back but i got to a point
where i'm on top of this girl and all
this stuff okay okay
and then like i actually don't think i
noticed it until like it was like over
i didn't smash or anything but until
we'd like decided like my balls are blue
i'm going to sleep yeah
um up until that point this is when like
one had got off
and then like turned to like the face
face the kind of thing
he must have been grinning he must have
been
grinning i can imagine ah he must have
been grinning
all night all night
he must have moved the muscle as well
that [ __ ] would not have moved
the most he was waiting for the owner
he was waiting for the opportunity
poised oh boy he's like a snake he's an
assassin
he is he can be an assassin he's an
assassin
rem's an assassin oh my stomach oh my
god right now
it's this hard in years remember your
actual assassin oh god
the funniest guy oh god i remember i
remember you telling me the morning
after but i don't
i can't remember it anymore bro yeah did
you see it years ago
you said it now i would i would never
remember that never remembered that
oh that was a that was literally over a
decade ago yeah
that was a long time ago wow the headset
now that was funny oh right let's do it
by the [ __ ] let's
[ __ ] you now um have you got one um i've
got quite a few actually to find them to
be fair yeah
jesus um
let's see if i can christ almighty
cool all right hi so basically me and my
baby daddy broke up two years ago
um i've been sleeping with him ever
since as well as others on different
occasions gang
um last year i got a dj gang at the same
time okay
we were just the same people [ __ ] it up
um lastly i got into a new relationship
with an old friend of mine from school
and he was so clingy and kind of bad in
bed peak
i ended up telling him i wasn't ready
for a relationship and he was crying and
being all emotional jesus
so i told him i wanted to go on a break
during this break
i immediately went back to my ex in
brackets i needed the nut
and was [ __ ] him for weeks before i
eventually told the guy i wasn't feeling
it
and wanted to end it and wanted to end
everything
oh i'm such an [ __ ] i'm going to come
back to it because i've screened
remember i told you i screenshot my
thing is i thought was the whole thing
two seconds guys i apologize
i am so sorry right now i will find the
whole thing
because that is juicy it won't take me
two ticks
um let me type in the name
boom okay where was i so i immediately
went back to my ex i needed the nut
and i was [ __ ] for weeks before i
eventually told the guy i wasn't feeling
it and i wanted to end everything
i then found out that he didn't want to
he didn't know what a break was
and he thought we were still together
that's awkward that is very awkward he's
silly as well from his part bearing in
mind hurt bearing in mind
he never found out about my ex am i the
answer for not making sure he understood
what was happening
he said oh she said to rather urban also
i don't know if you've talked about this
already but how do you guys feel about
mom bods
is it is the extra jiggle a turn off or
does it make a difference yes or no
so it's a two-pipe thing i'm assuming um
do you need the recap or are you
eager so see him straight so
she um has been [ __ ] a
baby's dad yeah on and off whilst
[ __ ] other people
yeah she reconnected with an old friend
from school yeah dick was bad and she
wasn't checking for him yeah so she said
i need some time to think this isn't
really doing it for me
she would immediately start [ __ ] her
ex for a few weeks yeah before she came
back to my mom was like actually
definitely want to lock this off
yeah he after talking they he then
realized that
she realized that he thought they were
together the whole time yeah they just
weren't talking or whatever
um she feels bad because she's up been
out getting piped while my man thinks
he's in a relationship with her and she
feels about that she didn't explain it
to him properly
um and now she wants to know is do we
fancy
mom odds two separate questions we'll
answer that one first and then we'll go
to one box
all right cool so what what are your
thoughts on that one um
it's a tough one he's
a massive [ __ ] from the sounds of it
crying you know
crying he must be big man he loves her
he loves her
he does he's not he's obviously never
been with
probably a girl like her this is
probably his first relationship or
something it's my assumption because
i don't know man i don't know how do you
i wouldn't cry off from a breakup
i don't think do you know what i mean no
i i know i've never cried from a breakup
i've never gone from a breakup i don't
know um but uh
anyway yeah that's that's how some
people don't even some people do cry
yeah
but anyway yeah um i feel like
i feel like for you maybe
he actually pro maybe does have a point
in that
your assumption was that he knew what a
break was but that's your interpretation
of what our breakers
i think a lot of different people would
have a lot of different interpretations
of what break is of course
um so i don't think yeah you should just
say i want to go on a break and assume
that we can [ __ ] whoever we want
because my girl could never tell me i'm
not really i'm struggling with this or
whatever if i feel
because obviously he's in deep mm-hmm
clearly so if i feel like we're
here yeah yeah and you're not feeling it
and you say i just need some time to
myself i want us
to go on a break yeah i don't want to
assume
that this is a free-for-all [ __ ] fest
now yeah of course and let's just [ __ ]
whoever we want for the next few weeks
until we decide that
that doesn't bode well with me at all
because even even then if i went on a
break
if i went on a break with my goal for a
few weeks or whatever
i found out that she's smashed anyone in
these few weeks we're not out here to
just be [ __ ] other people you know
if you want to [ __ ] other people you can
do that when we're together or you can
do it when you're single you can do what
you want
but like when people smash other people
on a break
it just makes me feel like perfect
example i've always thought when people
are smashing on a break
they're just using the break as an
excuse to have guilt-free sex with
someone else
she's proven that point to me i've
always thought that she's just proven it
to me
because she said the dick was bad so as
soon as they went on the break she went
and got some good dick
because she needed a nut she certified
my own paranoia
yeah and i am not happy about it
but anyway um you may be a little bit of
an [ __ ] because it probably sounds
like you should have explained yourself
um but at the same time
i think you're more of an [ __ ] not
necessarily for the not explaining thing
i think you're a bit more of an [ __ ]
uh
because you were clearly done this is
what i was going to say
is it yeah this that's the first thing i
was going to think of yeah yeah you
you take over so when you said when you
said about um how he's clearly
he's clearly in this he's like this you
guys are obviously on two
different pages and you've not made it
clear enough
that okay well you obviously know
he's in deep you could tell he's someone
when someone's in deep for you and
you're not
feeling it or the feelings aren't
reciprocated so at that point before
this breaking before you even
jump back to your ex's dick or whatever
you should have probably sat in down and
swinging to him like listen we're
clearly not on the same page
regardless forget this break thing we're
done we're clearly not on the same page
yeah because you're obviously two in
deep and i'm just not really feeling it
whether it's because the sex was ba
wasn't um the best if that was the
reason if that was the only reason i
feel like that's a little bit
shallow maybe maybe maybe maybe not but
again women are together not same as men
so i don't know that could be that could
be a different um topic completely but
i feel like you should have definitely
sat him down prior to this breaking been
like
you're clearly in this for different
reasons as to what i am and i'm not
feeling this as much
and maybe because you weren't feeling as
much that's probably why the sex was bad
you know
because when you're not feeling
something you're not really gonna want
to give yourself yeah exactly yeah
sexually yeah yeah yeah in terms of
intimacy you're just not so
you're just never ever gonna want to
nut from him and you're always because
of the fact that you've been [ __ ]
your ex in the past
and you already know what the sex is
like with someone else and you know
you're
he was gasps when she came back he's
just been chilling he's been chilling
minding his
business he was banging you and then
stopped
gotten with his life and then just
checked his messages here we go again
here we go again
strong dick game is a curse it's a curse
it's a gift and a curse it's a gift and
a curse
this one i don't want
[Laughter]
just like mine's just chilling here just
like oh she wants to [ __ ] me again
for god's sake all right i can't help
herself thursday
thursday come through um but i feel like
yes i feel like you must not necessarily
must know you are an [ __ ] in that
situation but like i said
you should have called it quits as
opposed to having a break because you
knew you weren't in this for the long
haul
clearly because your feelings weren't
the same yeah yeah as soon as
he was started crying you knew you
weren't about it yeah yeah so this break
was just like a way for you to
slowly break up slowly break up with him
and it wasn't the right move clearly i
feel like obviously he didn't want to
break his heart hence you reason why you
just chose the break first so we can
kind of
get some space between youtube clearly
it's just made it worse
it's just made it ten times worse
because obviously you did a little break
band-aid situation
just rip that band-aid off that band-aid
off man as [ __ ] as it sounds and as hard
as i'm assuming it might be
especially when you're the one not
feeling it as much as the other person
it's um it's a tough thing to do so
but yeah i guess you've learned your
lesson now i'm assuming if you get
yourself in a situation again you're ten
times out of ten
you're gonna just rip the band-aid off
rip that band-aid off it's not it's
better in the long run
clearly worth it man it is much better
in the long run for sure um and what
we're saying mombods
what are your thoughts yeah i mean i
feel like it's a bit of a like
it was a bit of a glancing statement
like i didn't really like the extra
define
extra jiggle what we're talking about do
moms have a fat or ass i don't think so
not in my experience assuming when she
says i'm i'm not assuming
i'm assuming she's not just talking
about harassing me maybe like her thighs
her stomach her arms
that's my assumption okay because extra
drink i doubt
i literally have a dad bodybuilder i
need the gym yesterday yeah
ah i love that [ __ ] but anyway uh the
i wouldn't say there's any extra
something something that makes it more
or less of a turn-on for me
it just would be ah that's a real i'm
really
sometimes i feel like people must get so
disappointed
in some of i cannot speak for myself but
some of my responses
because some things people can ask me
and i'll go deep into it
and there's some things that people
might think is another thing that i'll
go deep into
i'm just like i [ __ ] know how to
think about it and like
sometimes bodies are one of those ones
like you have your types that not
types but you know what you're attracted
to and you know what you're not okay i
don't know what i'm attracted to until i
see it yeah of course
i mean of course so i've never thought
about that's the thing as well that's
what another thing that i think
that we spoke about before is the
difference between men and women when it
comes to types
and i can only speak for me and the guys
i know and the women and the women that
i know
but in my experience women tend to have
specific types
if you if you give them a black and
white like this this and this they're
like
cool and they'll seek out that and
they'll be like that guy's my type i
find him attracted because he
is my title he checks off these he
checks off these things that in my head
i find attractive so
there we are there we are whereas i
could think oh that would be nice like
if she looked like this this she might
be like someone might see her no maybe
nicely
and then yeah but i don't really have a
type i just see something i think gang
there we go yeah i'm pretty much the
same like
i've never thought of what a mom bod is
because obviously
physique is different depends on your
height it depends on so much
sometimes some moms don't change nothing
bro if i think you look banging bing man
that's it you look banging i'm here to
i'm here for it yeah doesn't mean
for me to be fair actually there's
certain chicks that i've seen that i've
had a kid and it gets
thick i love thick i'm down for it i'm
down for it um
sometimes i've seen it um the opposite
way around as well
where like some chicks have a kid and
then they just they look like they lose
it
all they look like they lost all the
meat
i mean so it's each to our own and if
this lady is eating
if they're still banging and they're
still banging like i just thing
especially at our
age now maybe when i was like early 20s
if i found out like a
a girl that i was seeing had a kid i
might look
into it more and be like oh she looks
like this because of this
whereas at this age just like so many
people already have kids that it's not
even something that crosses my mind yeah
of course
of course it's just a thing i'm not for
or against yeah moms who have kids and
mum bods or whatever i'm just
like just is is what it is um
so yeah hopefully that answers yes
but yeah um it was a good one to be fair
i like the initial one but i'm the one
boss saying i don't think you should
don't swear don't swear so maybe you are
sweating about maybe you just want our
personal thoughts about it maybe you
don't give me to give a [ __ ] so
um but yeah i feel like me personally
and james obviously personally as well
it's not really something we think about
per se it's not something i've ever
looked into because like imagine going
on pornhub for example
you would never type in mumbai's which
someone does i bet some dirty [ __ ]
does mom bods
because you when you say dad bod
everyone knows what you're talking about
do you know what i mean yeah
there's a stigma yeah yeah whereas
big man kylie jenner's a man there we go
kylie jenner's a mum and her mum body is
probably different to someone else's mum
but for sure yeah i
understand and it just no it doesn't it
doesn't balance up it doesn't add up to
me but yeah it just depends on how you
view what a mom bod is to be fair so
yeah jenna's a mom so
right everyone's a mom it was a [ __ ]
mum there we are man i don't really i
don't really know what else you want us
to say with that but if
you're talking circles now if you're
banging your banging aren't really
careful yeah if you'll buff your buff
you're clearly you're getting enough
dick so there we go it doesn't matter
you're getting more dig than you need so
it doesn't matter stop thinking about
[Laughter]
peace
you